[Music]
what's Bing up some bachelor news get it
cuz they got pretty wild last night and
this is only episodes I mean I can't
even imagine what else is gonna happen
here but we don't have this goes right
Nancy every season you need a villain
okay bad Chad how can you forget him
exactly
well Corrine has quickly carved her
place into Bachelor infamy I want to get
even more romantic wasn't it so the plan
grab that trench coat in whipped cream
think he even saw on the show that I was
really caught off guard and you know
quite honestly I was a little
uncomfortable still that didn't stop
Nick from taking a taste in the moment
there troublemaker but when Nick then
pumped the brakes Corrine ran to her
room crying and slept through the rose
ceremony something no other contestant
has ever done worse
was crying and while many fans can't
believe she still got a rose nick is
defending his choice my decision to give
Corrine the Corbitt Rose wasn't it was
more based off the conversations that I
know a lot of which wasn't shown last
night what we did see was Karen's
ability to sleep through a group-date
nap count two before letting the ladies
in on this another nanny and you know do
you have kids no what do you I mean okay
so it's no surprise the 24 year old
invited Nick to a princess Playhouse in
a second attempt to seduce him
while Nick didn't seem to mind the rest
of the ladies let him have it while
Corrine went where else back to bed for
nap number three I'm not in touching
Corrine I'm judging your actions but it
sounds like Nick Eden gonna listen I
like women who are expressive and
confident and willing to take risks
[Music]
you